sorry Kelly the new guide knows how to
use his block Nick Jonas might be new to
the voice but he's coming in hot and
dropping power moves that was hurtful
thing good news I think I'm going to
lock you in it good Nick is here to win
here's what went down aspiring singer
Airy moon took the stage during
Tuesday's blind auditions and came out
swinging covering Kelly Clarkson's live
- her version of Miss independence
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah like I said came out so winging
anyway Nick was the first coach to slam
down on his button and turn his big red
chair around but it wasn't long before
Kelly followed suit
[Music]
Misun
little did she know Nick had used his
one and only block on Kelly to keep her
from claiming moon for 14
[Music]
yeah see how blocked is spelled out in
big-ass red letters on the floor well
Kelly was so wrapped up in the moment
she didn't even notice until she stood
up to applaud
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
sorry Kelly the new guide knows how to
use this block this is a game well
played Nick well played you already on
team Nick he effectively used his block
against the woman who made that song a
big hits willing to burn a bridge yeah
sorry it's savage but I kind of like it
is that messed up as soon as I heard two
notes in this independent I had to block
Kelly I was blown away by her powerhouse
voice Nick uses only block on me is
surreal and it's crazy like I'm very
flattered
[Applause]
then I got blocked like that was hurtful
things arey will move on as part of team
Nick and just to add a little salt to
the wound
Nick tweeted this pic of Kelly and that
big old block sign I also use my block
at one point very creatively which PPC
just crushing it to right now how how is
the dynamic been with girls in my song
oh oh and the girl with being in my jam
and it's fun you gotta get some revenge
on hip for that I'm saying
yeah Nick and Kelly actually tease the
epic moment to et back in January and
Nick who just joined the show for its
18th season revealed his strategy we
talked to Kelly a few weeks ago and she
said that you are too nice to attack as
a rival coach would you say that's your
strategy game plan game plan okay it's
nice and then when I come out with
things which happened later on you know
it started to warm up and heat up a
little bit when things get spicy it's
out of nowhere and they start to feel
like off balance because they thought I
was this nice person
I realize I'm a terrible terrible person
no you are guys but he is your wit came
out even more so like second day third
day tell you told us that you two had
kind of the most tension when it came to
people freaking Jonas
oh how intense did it get um no I mean I
think we both we're both really nice
humans in general but we're very playful
at the same time so um so it was fine
honestly and at the end of the day if
they're freaking the other person you
want them to go there because they
really want to end up with you so it's
kind of fine talk about friendly
sportsmanship I love it of course you
can count on et to bring you all the
latest from the voice season 18 so make
sure to keep it locked right here until
next time I'm Hallie Stevens I'll see
you soon
[Music]